il est 13h09 voilà le président à 13h09
regardez bien
il a deux bagues il a une montre
13h11
2 minutes après regardez bien
il n'y a plus de monde
Emmanuel Macron a donc enlevé sa montre
en cours d'interview et pour beaucoup
c'était pour ne pas avoir une montre de
luxe au poignet alors qu'il parlait de
la situation difficile de nombreux
frontières on a vu et on a vu tout et
n'importe quoi sur les réseaux on a
parlé d'une montre à 80000 euros est-ce
que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est une
montre de luxe à 80000 euros non
partout sur la région on a vu ça le prix
qui revient le plus c'est 80000 euros
sauf que c'est faux Gilles Verdez et on
a tous enquêté ici il s'agirait en fait
d'une montre bel&ros celle du groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la de la
République le GSPR les copains du gspa
les compagnies SPR et la valeur se
retourne de 2000 à 3000 euros donc voilà
donc c'est 2000 à 3000 euros pourquoi
l'actile enlevé après bon on aura Gilles
qui a eu l'Élysée sur les réseaux
sociaux ils sont nombreux à croire que
le président ne voulait pas porter des
signes de richesse au moment de parler à
des Français en colère et une autre
explication qui est avancée la montre
peut parfois gêner en tapant sur la
table en produisant des sons parasites
pour l'enregistrement ce qui se passe
c'est ce qui se passe d'ailleurs deux
secondes avant qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
l'enlève alors Gilles Verdez
alors ah oui on a on a d'ailleurs on a
pierre Alicia qui on n'a pas fait
rentrer pierre qui est là aussi pour
parler
les images regardez donc 13h09 il avait
la montre 13h11 il n'avait plus ça va
mon pire parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
pas on n'a pas le droit de mettre les
images sinon c'est 10000 €, merci mon
pierre merci d'être là à tous j'adore
continuer à communiquer et élu
d'Île-de-France et on va alors c'est
vrai que ça a fait le buzz aujourd'hui
tout le monde n'a parlé que de ça pierre
toi qu'est-ce que tu en penses vous avez
tout dit Cyril non mais la montre elle
est pas 80000
avant de parler de la montre il faut
quand même prendre conscience de
listérisation du débat politique et du
contexte actuel en ce moment c'est c'est
les proportions que prennent une une
rumeur lancée comme ça sur les réseaux
sociaux il a une montre à 80000 euros
de luxe qu'il ne souhaite pas montrer
s'il souhaite pas la montrer il l'avait
pas en fait et il la retire parce qu'il
parle de smicard en difficulté par
ailleurs on n'a pas vu les extrêmes
parce qu'on n'a pas le droit de les vous
n'avez pas le droit de les montrer mais
il ne parle pas à ce moment-là de
smicard en difficulté donc en fait il y
a une hystérisation du débat à partir de
rien à partir de d'une triple fake news
en fait la première c'est sur le montant
le coût de cette montre là qui n'est pas
80.000 euros c'est facilement vérifiable
montre logo t estampillé aux armoiries
de la présidence de la République bien
sûr que rien de plus normal pour le
président de la République d'avoir une
montre au contraire je préfère savoir
qu'il est une montre Élisée une montre
président de la République plutôt qu'une
montre de grande marque Pierre c'est que
on a vu tout moi tous les gens dans la
rue aujourd'hui et c'est ça me fait
plaisir ils m'ont tous arrêté ils m'ont
dit Cyril tu as vu la montre à 80000
euros du président est-ce que tu veux en
parler ce soir etc c'est vrai que ça
tout le monde avait sans tête et c'est
vrai que sur les sur les réseaux c'est
un truc de fou ça veut dire que c'est ça
part très vite et puis il y a un autre
permettre aussi que on n'a pas forcément
vous le savez parce que vous faites de
la télévision on est tous équipés de
micro ici donc lorsque si par exemple ce
soir quelqu'un du public m'investit on
l'entendra presque pas par contre nous
en studio on l'entendra c'est ça tout le
monde l'entendra par contre le
téléspectateur l'entendra pas donc à
partir du moment où vous parlez comme ça
avec les mains que vous avez une montre
métallique qui vient taper sur une une
table qui semblerait soit en verre soit
en plexiglas mais en tout cas qui fait
qui fait du bruit en fait dans le studio
en plus dans la sonalité du contexte à
l'Elysée interview du président de la
République on s'imagine qu'il y a pas on
n'entend pas une mouche volley à partir
du moment où ça tape une première fois
et on l'entend très distinctement juste
avant qu'il retire sa montre on l'entend
taper on peut penser qu'effectivement ça
vient gêner le président de la
République quand il s'exprime et qui
peut penser lui-même vu que ça fait un
bruit bien plus fort que ce qu'on entend
à la télévision qui qui juge assez utile
de et assez normal de l'enlever pour ne
pas à la fois parasiter son discours et
puis ne pas être gêné dans ses
mouvements les micros qui portent c'est
comme les micros qu'on a nous c'est les
micros qui qui amplifient le son de la
voix et qui atténue les bruits parasites
donc voilà c'est aussi simple que ça on
va on va voir Jean qui a eu le problème
sur ça aussi avec la quelqu'un ouais qui
faisait du bruit avec un micro c'est sûr
TPMP
[Rires]
2400 à la vente mais comme il y a un
partenariat c'est sans doute un petit
peu moins il faut savoir que cette
montre Emmanuel Macron l'aime beaucoup
il apporte pour de grandes occasions
alors l'Élysée m'a envoyé des photos il
l'avait par exemple Cyril lors de la
finale de la Coupe du Monde au Qatar ou
ici aux États-Unis là il a la
Nouvelle-Orléans lors de sa visite
d'État à Washington donc c'est une
montre qu'il aime beaucoup il l'avait
envoyé là au Qatar il l'avait pour la
finale de la Coupe du monde mais c'est
la montre voilà c'est ça montre qu'il
aime bien pour les grandes occasions
donc
là et la plus ça va c'est devenu il
avait monté à 80000 euros après c'est
devenu une montée alors qu'il parlait à
un moment de voilà après moi voilà je
vous le dis je suis pas et on les fait
un peu comme vous voilà sur la réforme
des retraites je trouve que le timing
est pas bon oui etc mais voilà la montre
là on va chercher les choses qui
n'existe quand même pas alors après il a
dépose sur la table il sait pas trop la
mettre il a une petite table sous à sur
le côté où il y a son et en fait dans le
studio il y a personne de son équipe
pour récupérer la montre parce que on a
dit il y a un plan serré du réalisateur
juste après pour que quelqu'un vienne
sortir la montre pas du tout personne
n'est rentré il y a les gens qui
s'occupent il y a les deux interviews il
y a 8 mais il y a personne de son équipe
pour retirer la montre donc il la pose
et c'est vrai qu'ils sont très surpris
de ce qui s'est passé sur les réseaux
sociaux pour qu'il communique quand même
à ce point-là pour qu'on les ait eu en
ligne etc c'est non pas qu'il y a une
inquiétude mais ils avaient envie de
tout de suite de casser la polémique et
à surgi et honnêtement moi je suis pas
souvent tendre avec Emmanuel Macron pas
particulièrement mais là il y a Miss
scandale ni polémique
celui qui a tué la fonction
présidentielle c'est François Hollande
le jour où il a dit un président c'est
un homme normal il a dit le plus grosse
connerie du monde c'est pas un homme
normal c'est le premier homme de France
le premier homme de la République il est
dans le G7 il doit pas être normal il
doit avoir une belle montre ils doivent
bien nous représenter être chic et beau
et je rappelle que Sar il y avait une
Rolex au départ et qu'ensuite sa femme
Carla Bruni lui a dit mais une Pattex
Philippe pardon c'est une marque très
cher c'est plus chic il avait une montre
à 80000 euros il est président de la
République on va pas lui une
Swatch et un truc Zara merde c'est pas
ça frank Michael quand il est venu dans
TPMP
non mais c'est effectivement on peut
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure le
président de la République a une montre
à 2000 €. franchement c'est même s'il
avait une montre à 10000 ans tu as
raison
non mais voilà tu as raison prends des
proportions par rapport au débat pour
lequel il était il était invité qu'ils
sont euh un peu lunaire pour en revenir
sur la sur la la marque la célèbre
marque de montre en plastique que vous
étiez pas merci en tout cas mon
professionnel
non mais sachez que moi j'ai travaillé
pendant plusieurs années je suis élu
aujourd'hui à la région de France avec
Valérie Pécresse j'ai travaillé pendant
des années avec Valérie Pécresse elle a
fait un choix qui est un choix délibéré
sciemment de ne porter que des montres
en plastique justement pour
ne pas ne pas avoir le moindre risque du
procès d'intention sur les médias
je dis simplement que quand vous êtes
sur un quand vous avez une déclaration
un plateau que vous avez un message à
faire passer si la montre que vous
portez prend plus d'importance que le
message que vous faites passer c'est que
vous avez perdu quelque chose donc le
fait de mettre une montre
comme celle que vous voyez ici à l'écran
passe partout que tout le monde a qui
n'a aucune valeur pécuniaire
particulière permet de ne pas être armée
de ne pas être parasiter sur le Trump
il y a Patrick Juvet qui dit
pas dans l'émission oui Delphine moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec Mathieu
combien même il avait une montre à 80
000 euros moi je préfère un président
effectivement qui a des signes
extérieurs de richesse mais qui écoute
ces français et qui incitent les gens à
devenir de plus en plus riche par le
travail plutôt qu'un président qui
enlève sa montre de peur de faire jaser
et qui fait du social à gogo et au final
on est mieux à la maison
il y a plein de gens qui disent genre
l'Élysée à parler à Gilles Verdez c'est
vrai que c'est la question
ah oui on a essayé de savoir avec les
comment comment avec les équipes on a
essayé de savoir toute l'après-midi ce
qui s'était vraiment passé et au bout
d'un moment effectivement on m'a dit que
le conseiller d'Emmanuel Macron allait
m'appeler à telle heure donc à 18h10
j'étais en loge c'est bon le conseiller
de d'Emmanuel Macron m'a appelé pour me
donner
de quoi
interviewer Bernard Menez sur sa
nouvelle pièce donc ils m'ont proposé
justement de avec eux j'ai réécouté
c'est exactement avec le time code pour
savoir à quel moment parce que vous
savez il y a une polémique qui est née
on dit on dit sur les réseaux qu'il
aurait retiré sa montre se rendant
compte qu'elle s'était une montre de
luxe au moment où il prononçait le mot
smicard donc déjà c'est pas une demande
de luxe avait montré mais c'est pas au
moment où il parle de Mika donc ça on a
étudié ça j'ai regardé dix fois la vidéo
il m'a envoyé les photos en disant que
c'est une montre qui portait tout le
temps ils m'ont même dit c'est une
habitude qu'il avait en réunion avec des
ministres souvent quand ça tape comme ça
même quand il y a pas de micro il retire
sa montre
donc voilà l'Élysée qu'est-ce que tu as
qu'est-ce Cyril
je pense que c'est ce que tu voulais
dire de la sorte de prolifération de
fake mur sur les réseaux sociaux de se
faire complotiste oui là il monte comme
ça mais on nous cache un truc mais là il
a mis là mais pourquoi parce qu'il veut
pas montrer que voilà c'est complètement
délirant
moi je trouve que c'est un honneur pour
nous enfin en tant que Français qui
porte une marque française qui a été
créée à 30 ans qui compte son salarié
vous préférez quoi qui porte une montre
hyper important qui a réussi qui est
venu là parce qu'il a beaucoup travaillé
et tant mieux pour lui c'est du faux
sont très difficiles et ben je serai
ravi pour lui qu'il ait une montre à 80
%
de vitesse mais c'est possible
sarkozyme dans la France d'aujourd'hui
là en ce moment qui est le moins
possible 80 000 ans
impossible je suis prenais pas possible
mais vous rendez pas compte non mais là
tu as 100
%. quoi c'est ce qu'on avait reproché
Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait prôné le
travail mieux payé etc et qui à peine
élu va au Fouquet de si ça la politique
s'est fait de symboles et quand tu as
une montre à 100000 € même si tu l'as tu
la mets pas ça oui
les imbéciles
un mot ce qui me beaucoup c'est que
finalement les mêmes qui aujourd'hui
enfin qui aujourd'hui et ces derniers
ces dernières heures on dénoncé une
montre soi-disant à 80 000 euros compris
que ça l'était pas d'ailleurs on sait
pas qui l'a payé cette montre est-ce que
la partie analysée est mise à
disposition auprès du président auquel
cas elle appartient à l'Élysée donc aux
Français et donc pas au président est-ce
que il l'a payé lui-même auquel Cassan
nous regarde pas il y a les mêmes qui
ont dénoncé cette montre soi-disant de
luxe sont on ne les entend pas dès lors
qu'il faut condamner justement toutes
les violences toutes les dégradations
qui pour à hauteur de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros vont être
financés par qui par nos impôts toutes
les dégradations qu'on voit dans Paris
et dans d'autres villes toutes les tous
les les moyens politiciens qui sont qui
sont mobilisés pour aller justement
essayer de limiter les violences et dans
le cadre de cette contestation là il y a
personne parmi ceux qui dénoncent cette
montre à 80 millions d'années
arrêtez de vous tromper c'est pas que la
nuit pèse c'est la LFI dans la rue qui
casse et qui font des trucs c'est tout
le monde c'est tous les français qui
sont en colère moi l'amour c'est pas
tous les
vous vous trompez c'est une montre à
2000 500 € de 1400 € prix d'achat 2400 €
prix d'achat mais avec un partenariat
donc on ne sait pas exactement à combien
eux donc elle est pas à 80 €. il
l'aurait enlever parce qu'il a eu des
idées parce que ça faisait du bruit oui
ça a tapé une fois voilà exactement donc
voilà donc c'est la mis de côté on en
est là après c'est vrai que Mathieu
Delormeau a dit un truc qui s'est
énormément réagir sur les réseaux
d'ailleurs on en a on a posé une
question vous avez les résultats dans un
instant est-ce qu'un président peut
avoir une montre à 80000 € comme il a
dit il a dit que pour lui ça le gênait
pas Sarkozy on avait hein
c'est un autre temps déjà je vous le dis
non mais malgré tout ça faisait
polémique arrêtez oui exactement déjà
non mais t'es malade de quoi tu vois le
président avec une montre à 80000 Cyril
un homme politique quoi un président
Premier ministre le Premier ministre
s'occupe de l'exécutif un président ça
s'occupe de représenter un pays il doit
quand il va à l'extérieur avoir un très
bon costume sur mesure une belle montre
une belle chemise
tu étais content quand il était en
Afrique en débardeur à boire des bières
que je te combinais ça vous choque
il a un gros poste et moi ça me choque
plutôt c'est une question de timing là
aussi oui quand les Français seront dans
la rue qui allaient problèmes de poids
lâcher
un président qui est censé te
représenter vous prenez les français
pour des imbéciles vous croyez au-dessus
tout le monde personne
je répondais à Mathieu qui disait c'est
des amis de Gilles et de la nupette qui
casse tout dans les rues peut-être qu'il
y a des gens qui cassent tout dans les
rues et on condamne on condamne ce qui
sont en train de faire mais vous vous
trompez tous en pensant bon alors moi
dans ma vie c'est pas les gens de la
nupette qui vont manifester il y a des
gens du Front national il y a des gens
qui ont voté Macron parce qu'il voulait
pas voter Marine Le Pen mais qui sont
dans la rue contre cette réforme moi la
montre je suis loin d'être je pense pas
être abruti pour penser qu'il a pas de
monte à 80 000 il était banquier avant
il a fait des sous avant d'être
président donc je pense vraiment qu'il a
une montre peut-être à 60000 à 70 000 à
40000 était grand bien lui fasse c'est
le discours qui fait là en ce moment et
c'est les dégâts qui fait en ce moment
c'est en ça que je veux qu'il soit c'est
que c'est ça qui me dérange tout à
l'heure vous parlez des discours
mais c'est plus ça moi le costume à 4000
euros
bien sûr déjà le personnage d'Emmanuel
Macron parfois est accusé d'être
arrogant de pas parler aux Français tu
l'imagines ce pardon avec une montre à
70 80 50000 euros c'est impossible mais
c'est un possible
il ne peut-il mais les Français feraient
la révolution de faire parler les
Français 80
000 euros les gens
écoutez
ce que tu dis que tu dis que c'est
impossible ce que tu es en train de
faire toi et d'autres vous êtes en train
de faire dans ce pays que chaque
personne riche est un ennemi arrêtez
avec non c'est le président de la
République c'est le président de tous
les frères de toute la nation tu l'as vu
la vérité il roule avec cette motards il
roule avec une bagnole privée
place ça coûte 50000 balles la minute
arrêtez ça c'est la sécurité c'est pas
la parole là tu parles de l'appareil et
alors tu parles de lui
paradentes mais c'est impossible Mathieu
c'est impossible que tu dis non
mais Macron c'est pas un rappeur il y a
pas venir avec une montre à 100000
balles et
avec une montre qui représente je sais
pas 7 ans 8 ans devant de salaire pour
certains enfin c'est complètement
incohérent qu'il en est dans le privé il
y en a plein qui font ça des
personnalités qui ont des biens
extrêmement cher ils sont servants
privés très bien mais en public et la
délicatesse de ne pas mettre une honte à
100000 balles d'habiter
le président de la République arrive pas
dépenailler avec effectivement des des
des locks sur lui un truc on est tout à
fait d'accord avec toi mais dans une
période de récession où les gens sont
dans la rue parce qu'il y en a qui
n'arrivent pas le 5 du mois c'est même
pas le 30 c'est le 5 du mois à boucler
leur fin de mois évidemment qu'il faut
que le symbole soit important et fort en
l'occurrence à la montre c'est de ces
2000 euros donc c'est tout à fait dans
les codes on va dire acceptable mais
mais évidemment que c'est pas une montre
à 80 000 et contrairement à ce que tu
dis le symbole c'est quelque chose bien
sûr qu'il faut qu'il soit élégant c'est
sûr qu'il faut qu'il représente la
France mais il y a évidemment des des
j'allais dire des outils
ne pense que aujourd'hui ce monsieur qui
a très bien réussi qui a de l'argent
porte une montre
Mathieu à ce point tu peux l'imaginer
tous les week-ends
merci Delphine problème en fait il y a
juste aucun problème vous prenez ça
comme c'était un truc du diable en fait
il y a aucun problème les gens qui
réussissent peuvent s'acheter des choses
qui coûtent un peu plus cher on sait
très bien qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a jamais
été au SMIC et tant mieux pour lui alors
il y a il y a un téléspectateurs qui
nous écrit souvent qui dit c'est un
président ne peut pas avoir une montre à
80000 euros alors qui peut ça ne me
gênerait pas c'est beaucoup pour moi le
symbole que vous parlez de symbole de
symbole c'est de la démagogie en fait et
je pense que s'il avait une montre en
plastique qui coûtait 200 balles en fait
là
il se fout vraiment de la gueule est-ce
qu'on est obligé c'est bon
alors pardon mais vous parlez d'empathie
vous parlez le fait que autant Cyril
qu'en Cyril par exemple interview des
gens très modestes ou des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à finir leur fin de mois
ou des gilets jaunes et alors il arrive
il est habillé ben non justement et que
par ailleurs c'est son argent
90 euros c'est l'argent des